Donald Trump was confronted with more
brutal chance of lock him up yesterday
at a Veterans Day Parade it has not been
so good for Donald Trump at public
events recently other than ones where
his audience is either hand-picked like
at rallies or in deeply parts of the
country like in Alabama over the weekend
Trump went to Game five of the major
league baseball world series in
Washington DC a couple of weeks ago he
was met by just relentless booing and
chants of lock him up last week he went
to a UFC fight in New York City also met
with relentless booing then he went to a
football game in Alabama and actually
got some cheers and then yesterday spoke
at a Veterans Day Parade in New York
City and it was ugly the crowd filled
with signs like impeach Trump signs that
say traitor criminal lock him up and
then of course the chance of lock him up
lock him up a throwback by the way I'm
realizing that some people may not know
what lock him up stems from this is a
throwback to the chance of lock her up
referring to Hillary Clinton over her
emails how quaint that seems now during
the 2016 Republican National Convention
you might remember now indicted former
Trump national security adviser Michael
Flynn was involved in leading a chant of
lock her up and we saw many others
during the 2016 presidential campaign
this is Trump's hometown New York City
and he's hated every public appearance
is becoming one of these please clap
moments for Donald Trump and let's be
really honest about the true
incongruence of Trump speaking at a
Veterans Day parade I am hard pressed to
think of a president less supportive of
our veterans than Donald Trump
he said he'd fix the VA in veteran's
health care he's not done it he's
attacked gold star families and gone to
war with the family of of deceased
military captain kazeer Khan he attacked
former prisoner of war late Senator John
McCain he said that avoiding sexually
transmitted diseases from women he slept
with was quote his own personal Vietnam
after getting a bogus doctor's note to
avoid going to the real Vietnam which by
the way I would have done the exact same
thing that was a complete
pointless and terrible military
engagement that's actually not what's at
issue here Trump wanted to use the
military for his own political gain by
having them go guard the border with
Mexico during a completely fabricated
immigrant caravan crisis which by the
way who whatever happened to that it's
no longer politically useful so it's
simply not being mentioned but expect
that it might experience a resurgence as
we get closer and closer to the November
of 2020 election he claimed to be
donating money to veterans charities got
the public relations benefit of those
donations but then never actually gave
the money aside from the fact that
crowds are increasingly hostile to
Donald Trump the guy has no business
whatsoever speaking at a Veterans Day
Parade I can't think of and I'm open to
hearing from you is there any other
president that has been more hostile to
the military and veteran community I
can't think of one at least not recently